c'est à 10h18 précisément ce matin que
la gendarmerie est appelée sur l'a 85
entre vierzon et angers à hauteur de la
commune de saint michel sur loire pour
une collision impliquant trois véhicules
selon les premiers éléments un poids
lourd en panne sur la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence et un véhicule cofiroute qui
le balisait aurait été percuté par un
autre poids lourd qui se serait déporté
sur la droite afin de laisser passer une
voiture qui le doublait si le conducteur
de cofiroute a réussi à s'écarter à
temps celui du premier poids lourd lui
est décédé une enquête est en cours pour
déterminer les causes de l'accident
des tests d'alcoolémie et des
vérifications concernant les stupéfiants
ont d'ores et déjà été réalisées